i'm off the grid for august and surprise
surprise they're still coming for your
kids
this is now instructing teachers to
educate children starting in
kindergarten to experiment with
non-binary pronouns just to kind of
destroy human civilization and throw it
all into chaos and confusion that's
actually happening by the way why is a
school talking to your kindergartners
about sex shouldn't they be in prison
for doing that yes they should be chris
ruffo has proved this is going on he's
obtained several documents from the
district's equity department he joins us
tonight chris thanks so much for coming
on tell us what exactly is going on here
if you would
so what's happening is that public
school bureaucrats across the country in
this case in los angeles have taken the
principles of academic queer theory and
then turned them into a k through 12
pedagogy they're training kids as young
as kindergarten to experiment with
sexual identities uh such as trans
genderqueer pansexual gender fluid
two-spirit all of these uh really crazy
and synthetic uh constructions that were
we once thought were relegated to
academia they've now been mainlined into
elementary school classrooms
all over the school district in los
angeles
i'm really i mean this sincerely i'm
confused if i find your kindergartner in
the park and start talking to her about
her sex life you have a moral right to
punch me out and call the cops
why in the world are we allowing
teachers to do the same thing
well i think a large part of the reason
is because of this illusion of authority
and so the two prominent domains where
these ideas are being transmitted are
education and the medical profession and
you know for better or worse
historically these have been very
trusted so people listen to teachers
they listen to doctors
but i think this is starting to change
because this is getting frankly out of
control and one thing that is really
important to know that actually school
districts like los angeles have adopted
an explicit policy that teachers can
facilitate your child's gender or sexual
transition and the default policy is
that they keep it secret from parents
so they know that they're doing
something that parents would object to
i have the documents that prove exactly
what they're doing and they're trying to
keep it a secret
i mean up until recently the rule was
you troll my
minor children about their sex life and
you're going to get hurt and i think
that should be the rule still i think
this is that it's that threatening i
appreciate all you've done
to bring this to like chris ruffo thank
you